bonjour à tous et à tout bon jour il ce
but si l'invité de sao qu'a dit ce matin
et jean-joseph malidor bonjour bonjour
monsieur oui alors vous êtes président
de l'association prévoyance créole qui
vient d'éditer avec l'ireps l'instance
régionale d'éducation de prévention un
jeu pédagogique sur la nutrition santé à
l'intention prioritairement des enfants
âgés entre 6 et 11 ans et dans votre vie
professionnelle on le précise jean
joseph malidor vous êtes médecin au
d'odontologie sts chef de service au chu
de martinique alors présenté nous cette
association dont vous êtes le président
quelles sont ses actions à l'association
prévoyance créole m merci de me donner
la parole à laon la vocation de
l'association de prévoyance créole à pcc
de négocier auprès des assureurs et des
réassureurs les meilleurs produits pour
ces pour ses adhérents et nous confions
cette gestion à la dette
mais au-delà de cette vocation première
nous avons aussi un fonds social qui
nous permet d'aider les gens qui sont
magnifiques de nos adhérents bien sûr
qu'ils sont en difficulté
et puis nous avons d'autres actions
beaucoup plus social donc je peux vous
énumérer quelques unes parce que nous en
avons beaucoup l'assistance déjà aux
personnes et aux familles en difficulté
à nous en avons dans le calme par
exemple de certains un séisme on le sert
d'un cyclone ça nous arrive d'aider nos
adhérents qui peuvent pas payer leurs
cotisations qui peuvent le bon c'est le
cas aussi par exemple des nous avons des
prévention sanitaire et social dans ce
cas là nous faisons le ce jeu par
exemple nous pensons à la santé nous
nous y sommes justement joseph mais elle
met en avant d'autres
oui il est compagnon madoff en exemple
encore parce qu'on lui a offert tout cas
laisse évidemment
alors donc là effectivement et publié
les nutri héros en route vers ta santé
donc vous avez participé
votre association à l'élaboration de ce
guide ludique en fait autour donc de la
saine alimentation
tout à fait alors en fait de toujours
dans la vocation de l'apc nous avons
initié cette idée et qui a été mise en
musique je dirais par par l'hiver
tout simplement parce que l'ireps avait
les compétences ou cela et nous voulions
à tout prix coller à cette je dirais à
cette volonté de faire en sorte que nous
apprenions à nos enfants à bien se
nourrir mais surtout à à bouger sans
fait la lutte contre l'obésité
parce que faut savoir qu'en martinique
nous avons pour les plus de 16 ans 61%
de personnes qui sont en surpoids et
parmi ces soixante et une personnes
minces et 61%
nous avons à peu près 25% qui sont en
situation d'obésité
ça veut dire qu'il n'y mc supérieur à 30
il faut savoir que chez les enfants
c'est un peu moins 116 % de population
d'enfants de moins de 16 ans qui sont en
surpoids dont 8% en situation d'obésité
et ça ça a des conséquences énormes sur
la suite peu de leur vie
c'est le surpoids c'est déjà le
bien-être en soi même la considération
que l'on peut avoir vis-à-vis des autres
mais surtout les maladies
cardiovasculaires le diabète
l'hypertension et c'est bien pour ça que
nous sommes les champions en hyper
torture et en obésité avec tout le
corollaire des maladies
cardiovasculaires qui viennent voilà
donc un jeu pédagogique
on est là dans l'ordre de l'éducation
donc à la bonne alimentation on l'a dit
joseph malidor président de
l'association prévoyance créole comment
se présente donc ce jeu ce jeu les nutri
héros donc en gros les héros de la
nutrition quoi on va voilà en route vers
ta santé alors comment comment il se
présente je suppose que vous avez fait
un effort pour qu'il soit de manière à
plaire aux enfants quoi
dans sa conception pédagogique oui je
vous dirais plusieurs choses la première
c'est que nous estimons que si
l'éducation ne peut pas être faite par
les parents
elle peut être fait par les enfants
c'est que nous estimons que lorsqu on
apprendra un enfant à bien se nourrir à
lui dire ce qui est bien
je nous restons persuadés qu'il obligera
les parents aussi
et donc ils éduquent rasées par des noms
que je pense que c'est une chose ensuite
on lui a rappelé andré à l'égout savoir
ce qui est bon parce qu'aujourd'hui en
fait les le mode de vie a changé nous
sommes beaucoup plus sédentaire
nous prenons notre voiture pour faire
100 m non en fait on n'a pas l'activité
privée de d'être d'activités physiques
depuis deuxième point nous absorbons
beaucoup de graisse je ne peux pas citer
de sandwichs rapide
enfin et et puis le sucré alors on va on
va venir au à cet aspect du goût parce
qu'effectivement c'est quelquefois
délicat avec avec ce public là mais
revenons sur la présentation de ce jeu
qui est on nous dit que c'est un peu sur
le principe de la roue de la fortune
alors bon voilà enfin les enfants
doivent faire tourner une roue qui a
plusieurs couleurs oui donc c'est un peu
ça le principe avec des dons que des
aliments dessinée quoi faire des
produits alimentaires destinés
oui alors en fait de nous faisant la
présentation officielle aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs à les actes de pelletier à
11h et d'ailleurs je profite pour
inviter tous ceux qui veulent participer
à cette présentation mais qui peut venir
à l'essai de pelletier à 11 heures où
nous allons présenter nous allons
l'expliquer nous allons même faire jouer
des enfants parce que nous avons invité
des enfants et ce sera l'occasion pour
chacun où les télévisions qui veulent se
déplacer de pouvoir filmer et pour
beaucoup d'autres qui voudront bien bien
comprendre le jeu je pense qu'il sera
mieux expliquer certainement par madame
va me je remercie d'ailleurs parce
qu'elle était vraiment la créatrice et
et elle a animé de pouce pour cet
ensemble mais voilà le jeu en fait c'est
une roue de la fortune ou les enfants
auront des cartes ils auront des défis à
faire c'est assez long à expliquer mais
je vous invite vraiment alors voila mais
par exemple un exemple de ce qu'ils
peuvent pour ont trouvé combien de
portions de fruits et légumes verts est
il recommandé de manger chaque jour
c'est a su comme incidence sur les
études par exemple que nous avions
beaucoup plus de fric il n'en fallait un
gros coup plus de graisses qu'il en
fallait
voyez donc là attention à l'abus de
fruits finalement pas ce qu'on nous dit
et à la vue le vrai ceci donc voilà
souvent il ya il ya dans les besoins
alimentaires des besoins de
nutritionnelle il faut un certain nombre
de parts de catégorie d'aliments
aussi il nous faut une part d'aliments
enfouis et qu'on en mange 5
ça va pas agir si on mange s'il faut 5 5
portions de grèce alors qu'il en fallait
une
on peut scolaire mais quand je regarde
il veut aussi donc il ya un volet
éducation au goût
avouez vous faisiez allusion aux
capacités et aux quantités et aux
associations et aux associations
évidemment bien sûr mais le goût le goût
c'est pas facile avec ce public
d'enfants qui souvent est attiré par ce
qui est bon sur le plan des gustatif
mais qui est souvent ces mêmes c'est
comme ça c'est à dire que c'est très bon
goût mais ça peut être mauvais pour la
santé et inversement
ce qui est parfois très bon pour la
santé n'est pas agréable au goût et bien
avec les enfants c'est un peu comme l'a
vu il ya des choses qui sont
conditionnés si on est ensuite on
apprend très tôt à manger beaucoup de
sucre ben voilà on continuera par contre
si on apprend à voir le vrai goût des
aliments faire découvrir la texture des
aliments le goût des aliments
et puis bien sûr l'intérêt à manger ces
aliments là je me suis persuadé que
l'éducation est le sauveur c'est ta joie
je parlais de la présentation est ce
qu'il est question quand même d'une
alimentation aussi d'une bonne
alimentation basée sur les produits
balocco les produits d'un art uniques
qui sont bon pour notre santé
la plupart vous savez nous avons
beaucoup de croyances a joué juste un
exemple d'un travail qui a été fait par
le parme
savez vous que la pomme de terre est
beaucoup plus néfaste que les shoots
chine ou éventuellement que le flop
puisque l' indice glycémique est
meilleur pour ces aliments donc à notre
disposition en martinique nous avons des
aliments qui sont nettement meilleures
que ce qui est importé si on apprend à
nos un fromage et des frites par exemple
de de patates douces ils sont nettement
meilleures que des frites de pommes le
vern et et qui sont non seulement
beaucoup plus agréable mais aussi
beaucoup plus digeste et qui n'apportent
pas autant de sucre qu'une que les
pommes de terre
donc ça s'est expliqué dans ce que nous
apprennent alors on termine donc cet
ouvrage il sera disponible ou vous voilà
vous avez l'intention de vous adresser à
alors aux écoles bien sûr on pense
évidemment mais peut-être pas que alors
je voulais une explication soul et l'apc
qui a fait jeudi et qui le regroupement
de tous les adhérents à qui nous
confions notre gestion à l'adep la dette
existe non seulement sur la martinique
la guadeloupe la guyane la réunion et
mayotte
donc avec ce fonds social nous allons
privilégier d'abord les départements sur
lesquels nous existons et donc nous
avons ce test jeu qui sera fait en
martinique en guadeloupe en guyane à la
réunion et à partir du succès de ce jeu
nous éditerons d'autres exemplaires
aujourd'hui nous avons à peu près 100
exemplaires
ça nous a coûté un peu d'argent mais ils
nous tenons à ce que ce soit une
réussite au pour le département à terme
on peut envisager qu'ils se mettront
également dans les foyers nous
souhaitons que chacun s'approprie ce jeu
exactement comme monopoly ou mais nous
souhaitons surtout faire l'éducation non
deux enfants pour que même face
l'éducation d'euros par an voilà un jeu
avec dites vous des règles simples
adaptés au jeune public merci jean
joseph malidor président donc de
l'association prévention créole
donc à propos de ce jeu pédagogique qui
vient d'être édité vous allez présenter
ce matin l'autre au lamentin sur le
thème un jeu pédagogique sur le thème de
la nutrition
c'est avoue yves bertrand ce que vous
avez retenu les frites de patates douces
oui oui que c'est mieux que les frites
de pommes de terre voilà il faut pas
qu'elle soit trop grave
ce travail a été fait par le pam avec
une grande liste de tous nos produits
avec les indice glycémique et je vous
assure que nous avons la meilleure
alimentation du monde possible
allez bonne journée sur martin caceres
22 ans merci merci à tous les deux
[Musique]